hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
Hana Arendt provided a course on the
history of political theory back in 1955
and she typed out her lectures and these
are available in the the archives and
the conclusion to that particular course
has a very interesting discussion that
touches on the point and purposes of
philosophy and its relation with
politics and political conditions as
well as with other things and she uses
this master metaphor of the desert sand
storms and Oasis philosophy turns out to
be one of the oases and the life in
which we live which is a life in which
we have to engage in what what she very
broadly speaking called politics is the
desert the desert of modern life so
within just three pages she sets out a
very interesting set of considerations
for us that help us understand what
philosophy might be good for in ways
that go quite different from from other
controls of philosophy so she tells us
that the the desert is the world under
whose conditions we move and she calls
this the withering away of the
in-between the growth of world lessness
the spread of the deserts and she says
that the desert was actually first
recognized by Friedrich Nietzsche and if
you remember your nature you know that
he was very concerned about the
development of modern culture which he
saw as largely modes of of degeneres and
reaching a certain time period in which
nihilism would become the main problem
of our era he thought that was actually
going to be the main issue of the 20th
century and you may have
Ben correct and he thought that people
would find all sorts of ways to try to
avoid this but none of them would be
ultimately successful and Arendt says
that this desert was first recognized by
Nietzsche but it was also Nietzsche she
says who made the decisive first mistake
in diagnosing and describing it and then
she says that it's not just Nietzsche
everybody else following him has been
seeing this the same way as well
what is this fundamental mistake he
believed the desert is in ourselves and
so he says she says it was precisely in
this diagnostic he revealed himself as
one of the first conscious inhabitants
of the desert so if the desert is not
simply in ourselves with then the
meaning would happy we have to cultivate
something in ourselves but rather it's
out there and the way in which we do
live with each other or fail to live
with each other then we have to have
different ways of approaching it and she
tells us that the modern psychologists
have essentially followed Nietzsche in
this she says that we have a psychology
of the desert and by the same token the
victim of the most terrible illusion in
the desert is that we begin to think
that there's something wrong with us
because we cannot live under the
conditions of desert life so modern
psychology and by this I think she means
not primarily Experimental Psychology
but psychotherapy and all the theory
that accompanies it she says that when
psychology is trying to help people what
it's really trying to help them do is to
adjust themselves to a world that
doesn't have to be the way that it is
and is really screwed up and is lacking
not just in meaning but in what would
sustain us a world in which were forced
into the wasteland into the desert so
people learn to deal with that learn to
cope learn strategies
and the deserts can be of many different
kinds you could picture the desert of
consumerism as well you know in our own
Internet age where everything seems to
be available not just in terms of buying
products on say Amazon or wherever else
you want to go but just in the sheer
amount of information that's floating
out there and yet our young people and
many of our old people lack the
information literacy to be even minutely
critical about the sources that they're
deriving this information from and we
have you know problems with the main
sites that were relying upon all the big
tech companies even sites like Wikipedia
where we know that there's many things
wrong with it these are all part of what
she's calling the desert and so
psychology she says tries to help us
adjust to the conditions of desert life
this takes our only hope away and what
is this hope it would be that she says
we who are not on the desert but who
live in it would be able to transform
the desert into a human world we would
need to do that through action which
requires as she says a little bit later
in this courage and the psychology of
the desert militates against it instead
it teaches us how to fit in better and
to not expect quite so much so she says
that psychology makes everything
topsy-turvy because we suffer under
desert conditions we're still human
we're still intact the danger is that we
become truly inhabitants of the desert
and feel at home in it we take that as
the new normal we shorten our horizons
we shorten our gaze towards the depths
and now say well this is OK like that
old meme that you see with a dog sitting
in the room where everything is on fire
saying to himself this is all right so
that's what she takes that as do
then she talks about another type of
danger if one of the dangers in the
desert is that of drying out of becoming
desiccated another is of sandstorms
what are sandstorms in this case she
says that the desert is not always the
quiet of the cemetery where after all
everything is still possible but whips
up a movement of its own
what are these totalitarian movements
whose danger lies precisely in the fact
that they are so extremely well adjusted
to the conditions in the desert
now Arendt lived through totalitarianism
she saw what happened not just within
Nazi Germany which she escaped from
fortunately because she was actually
marked for extermination herself but
went on to do an entire study on the
origins of totalitarianism that many
people purchase and check out on the
library but don't read in its fullness
because it is so encyclopedic in its
examination and so deep in its
theoretical investigation totalitarian
movements appeal to those who are within
the desert it because they provide some
sort of ready-made meaning they provide
a mode of action they provide excitement
they provide being alive they allow you
to indulge things that are otherwise
recognizable as wrong but people get
into that and all sorts of thoth Eliot
totalitarian and totalizing movements
would do this she says that they reckon
with nothing else than the desert and
therefore seem to be the most adequate
political forms of desert life and then
she says both psychology is the
discipline of adjusted human life in the
desert and totalitarian movements
threaten the two faculties of the human
being with which we may be able to
patiently transform the desert rather
than transforming just ourselves the
Faculty of passion and the Faculty of
action the Faculty of action is doing
something doing something not just only
on our own
but with others who we have to in some
way speak to in order that we can
cooperate but the Faculty of passion is
involving what she calls here it the
virtue of endurance she says only those
who can endure the passion of living
under conditions of the desert can be
trusted with summing up in themselves
the courage which lies at the root of
all action of becoming an active being
and indeed living out the Vita Activa
the act of life that she thought was so
central so those who lose themselves in
totalitarian movements because that
provides them with a ready-made identity
and course of action or anything along
those lines those who buy into the just
adjust yourself to the conditions that
exist she's saying they're not the ones
who should be transforming things
because they're already ok with the
desert as it is now the sand storms also
she says threaten what we call oasis the
owaisi's in the desert without which
none of us could endure it
she says psychology tries to get us so
accustomed to desert life we shall no
longer feel any need for oasis the sand
storms could swamp them what are these
oases she tells us that they are the
fields of life which exist independently
or largely so from political conditions
so they're not reducible to to that and
as a matter of fact individuality and
relations between individuals personal
relations become incredibly important in
this light they're not supposed to be as
she says a little bit later they're not
supposed to be escapes they're not
supposed to be mere refuges for
relaxation you're not being taken out of
the frontlines to do some R&R hedonistic
aliy away from the front before being
thrown back in if we want to use that
sort of metaphor and she talks about the
danger
involved in these sorts of things she
says that oases are not relaxation they
are the life spending Wells which enable
us to live in the desert without
becoming reconciled to it without
becoming reconciled to it so that we
don't say desert that's fine because I'm
gonna get my fun over here she says that
there's an opposite danger escapism to
escape from the world of the desert from
politics into whatever it may be think
about all the things that people use as
the escapes in the present for example
gaming or endlessly watching YouTube
videos or just watching streaming
contents and then entering into fandom
that may in fact you know have a nice
little conflict here and there
who's shipping who and you know what
representation is going on here but but
it really all ends up being a kind of
politics as a way of commodifying things
a way of just expressing your own
individuality it's essentially
consumerism just in another way an
escapism
it could be escapism of taking drugs and
partying and you know trying to not
think about tomorrow that's a form of
escaping ISM as well the everything is
crap doom and gloom and sort of
indulging oneself and that would also be
escapism she says that this is less
dangerous and a more subtle form of
ruining the owaisi's than the sandstorms
which threaten its existence by escaping
she says we carry the sand of the desert
into the oasis now that's important when
we think about what the owaisi's
actually are so let's let's take a look
at the the Owaisi she talks about she
doesn't say that these are the only
possibilities but she names four of them
as centrally important and remember when
we're talking about this we're not
talking about just any old form of this
we're talking about what you might call
the essence of it expressed in the
individual or in the personal so she
says
here we go these oases are all fields of
life existing independently or largely
so from political conditions what went
wrong it is politics that is we insofar
as we exist in the plural and not what
we can do and create as we exist in the
singular in and now she says isolation
like the artist in solitude like the
philosopher in the inherently world
lists relationship between man and man
as it exists in love and sometimes in
friendship
so she describes these a little bit she
says friendship when one heart reaches
out directly to the other or when in
passion now we're talking about love the
in between the world goes up in flames
so we have these these four things she's
talking about arts and not just the
production of art but also the
appreciation of art the world of the
desert is one in which art becomes mere
commodity mere background or gets all
sorts of prizes it's essentially
domesticated the world of art would
probably also include that of music as
well then we have the world of
philosophy does she mean at philosophy
in an academic sense no as a matter of
fact a rental is very harsh towards
academic philosophers she talked about
the fact that they tended to spend their
time writing articles that nobody would
read and she was saying that back in the
1950s and 60s no she means philosophy in
a very broad sense where philosophy
actually intrudes into these other
fields like art but also politics and
other areas as well where it could
inform a better psychology as well
love eros desire romantic relationships
sexual relationships those are between
people those of course can become a
matter of mere pleasure seeking and
escapism that's where people drag the
sand into the oasis but
can also be the source of an intimacy
that is different than an intimacy of
friendship what the medieval is called
conjugal love which was consummated
through actually doing it right having
sex and all the other things that go
along with that friendship again does
she mean Oh Facebook friends and
everybody I call my acquaintances no she
means a deep abiding connection between
people who get to know each other and
find something that they respond to in
the other and who using Aristotle's
formula whish well to the other for the
others own sake these provide us with
oases all of these are completely
contingent all of these could be
destroyed by the sand storms of
totalitarian movements all of them could
have their wells dry up all of them can
have sand dragged into them and become
unusable because people are using them
as modes of escape but used rightly they
allow us to live in the desert and not
be of the desert and allow us to think
that we might be able to do something
else with this desert so she says that
this is towards the end of this
discussion the world is always a desert
who needs those who are beginners to be
started anew in it there's never the
right time for transforming it but we
will need these owaisi's in order to do
that and she says out of the conditions
of desert which started with the
beginning of world lessness in the
modern age grew the question why is
there something at all and not rather
nothing out of the modern world
condition where we are threatened not
only with no thingness nothingness but
with nobody nests we may grow the
question why is there somebody at all
and not rather nobody or the generic
this is about individuality and
being particular single but doing so in
a way that connects us with a world that
doesn't need to remain merely a desert
so if we think through this and we use
this as a way of conceptualizing the
activity of philosophy we would see
philosophy quite differently I suspect
than we would if we were looking at it
in a strictly academic sense whatever
the fads of the time happened to be and
we see that philosophy beer is a deep
kinship with art with love with
friendship as an activity of the human
being
you